so we have two examples here someone
trying to find the derivative of an
expression or on the left hand side it
says avery tried to find the derivative
of 7 minus 5x using basic
differentiation rules here is her work
and on the right hand side it says
hannah tried to find the derivative of
negative three plus eight x using basic
differentiation rules here is her work
and these are two different examples
preferentiation rules exercise on khan
academy and i thought i would just do
them side by side because we can kind of
think about what each of these people
are doing correct or incorrect so these
are similar expressions we have a
constant and then we have a first degree
term a constant and then a first degree
term
so they're going to take the derivative
so let's see step one for avery she took
she's separately taking the derivative
of seven and separately taking the
derivative of
five x
so this is uh my spider sense is already
going off here
because what happened to
this negative right over here
so it would have made sense for her to
do the derivative
of
seven
and she could have said minus the
derivative of 5x
that's one possibility that she could
have done the derivative of a difference
is equal to the difference of the
derivatives we've seen that property or
she could have said the derivative she
could have said this is equal to the
derivative of 7
plus
the derivative with respect to x of
negative 5x
these two things would have been
equivalent to this one but for this one
she somehow forgot to
include the negative so i think she had
a problem
right at step one
now if you
just follow her logic after step one
let's see if she makes any more mistakes
so she takes the derivative of a
constant so constant isn't going to
change with respect to x so that makes
sense that that derivative is 0
and so we still have the derivative of
5x and remember
it should have been negative 5x or minus
the derivative of 5x and let's see what
she does here so that 0 disappears and
now she takes the constant
she takes the constant out and that's
true the derivative of a constant times
something is equal to the constant times
the derivative of that something
and then she finds that the derivative
with respect to x of x is one and that's
true if the slope if you had the graph
of y equals x the slope there's one or
what's the rate of change at which x
changes with respect to x well it's
going to be one for one so the slope
here is one so this is going to be five
times one
which is equal to five and at the end
they just say what step did avery make a
mistake so she clearly made a mistake at
step one
this right of here should have been a
negative if that's a negative then that
would have been a negative then this
would have been a negative then that
would have been a negative and then her
final answer should have been should
have been a negative five
now let's go back to hannah to see if
she made any mistakes and where
so she's differentiating a similar
expression so first she takes the
derivative of the constant plus the
derivative of the first degree term
derivative of a constant is zero that
looks good so you get the zero and then
you have the derivative of the first
degree term that's what she's trying to
figure out
and then
let's see she's taking
okay so this is this seems off she is
assuming that the derivative of a
product is equal to the product of the
derivatives that is not the case
and especially and it's if you have a
constant here there's actually a much
simpler way of thinking about it frankly
the way that avery thought about it
avery had made a mistake at step one but
this is actually going to be equal to
the derivative of a constant times an
expression is equal to the same thing as
the constant
times the derivative of
of the expression so this would have
been the correct way to go and then the
derivative
of x with respect to x well that's just
going to be 1. so this should have all
simplified to 8.
what she did is she is assume she tried
to take the derivative of 8 and multiply
that times the derivative of x that is
not the way it works in the future you
will learn something called the product
rule but you don't even have to apply
that here because one of these one of
these components i guess you could say
is a constant so this is the wrong step
this is where hannah makes a mistake and
you can see instead of getting her final
answer of 8 she's getting a final answer
of she assumes well the derivative of 8
is 0 times the derivative of x is 1 0
times 1 and she gets 0 which is not the
right answer so she makes a mistake at
step 3 and avery made a mistake at step
one